my name is Hao and I work for the Apache
MX net science team at Amazon AI which
is part of it abyss and today we're
gonna introduce a new package that will
help you with accelerating your numpy
workloads so firstly let me introduce a
bit about Apache mix net so it is an
open source deep learning framework and
you know we have a team dedicated on it
at AMS and this MPI mix net is our new
numpy compatible interface that will
allow our users to retain their familiar
numpy interfaces of functions ap is I
mean while also leveraging the
parallelism of modern computer hardware
and we also want to provide extra deep
learning related features to our users
so let's visit what does this exactly
bring so one thing we want to ensure is
definitely the interoperability with
numpy another thing we bring is the
parallel acceleration for it before all
the existing numpy operators and also we
are adding extra operators and functions
for deep learning related workloads and
one last thing we want to add is the
automatic differentiation functionality
so let's dive deep into each of them so
let's take a look at this piece of code
we are importing the numpy module from
mix net and we also imported the
official numpy as OMP and we are
initializing two tensors within so we're
learning to MX vampire and the erase and
we are trying to add them up with
official vampires function we can see
this works and the result is still a MX
9 vampire in the array and we can also
sum on certain axis of the result the
result is still a MX net vampire in the
array so we can see this is
interoperable with official numpy
so the next thing is that we are
bringing parallel acceleration to the
operators so here let's take a look at
this example here
so we're importing the official number
just as MP and we're initializing two
large tensors which one is 2048 by 1152
and this server has 32 CPU cores which
is already high BP very powerful so the
dot actually took point zero eight
seconds I wouldn't say this is slow but
you know you would expect something more
from you know when you are paying for
that kind of powerful server right so
let's take a look at when we switch the
library to the NPR mix net so here you
can just so here we're just switching
the library but we're keeping the code
the same right so one thing to note is
that right now we are just setting the
default type to be in mp on mix net is
just a single precision float so we
don't have the extra typecast here and
this thought now on the same machine
finish within about 0.06 seconds which
is a 1.3 speed up with was just a drop
in switch so we want to take it further
and we want to put this operation on GPU
to further speed up is to further speed
it up so now let's see how do we put it
on GPU so here we have a car called as
in context which will just put your
tensor on GPU so the GPU has has if you
have multiple GPUs you can just index
them by their ID so here we're just
using one GPU and
ideas just zero so we just put all those
two tensors onto the zeros GPU of our
system and if we just still perform the
dot product as usual the computation
will just automatically happen on GPU so
this dot product finished within point
zero zero two seconds which shows about
a forty two times speed up with just two
line changes so the third feature I'm
trying to talk about is the new extra
operators that we are adding in the MPX
namespace so which include a lot of deep
learning specific functions like
convolution operator pooling operator so
like let's take a look at what is
convolution operator so you apply a
kernel onto a an image and then you
multiply the weights in the kernel or or
filter somebody may call it element wise
with the input data that it covers and
you sum them up to get the final result
so pooling is a bit similar but without
the filter you just try to derive one
number from from a certain pool so
convolution is used widely as a feature
extractor on images so let let's take a
look at this example this those are the
filters or convolution kernels trained
on the NIST data set which is the
handwritten digits and we can see that
it's trying to figure out it's trying to
find out like dots and those features
like thoughts and edges and some
patterns so this convolution really
works well a lot of data is even an
audio data image data video data as a
strong feature extractor so for
activation functions we're providing a
wide range of them like sigmoid and and
also okay and also the key value
function
so all those are easily implemented with
official umpire but we're just making a
life easier by providing them directly
to you in MPX namespace and we also
provide bash norm drop out and so on so
the the last feature I want to talk
about is the automatic differentiation
so when you are building some model and
you need to know that your outputs
gradient respect with respect to its
input variables or the parameters of the
model if you just want to write it in
lime pie because numpy does not that
naturally provide the backboard function
for you you'll have to implement it
yourself but here was the automatic
differentiation we are doing this for
you and you can get access to you know
your backward gradients in an easier way
so let's take a look at this code
example so we are importing an extra
module which is called AutoCAD and here
we are just performing another dot
product between the two tensors okay so
here we're just performing another dot
product between the two tensors and
before we perform this we want to attach
two extra buffers to the to import
answers to hold their gradient when the
backward propagation is done right and
then we wrap the computation up with
this autocrat record scope which will
keep track of what kind of operations
you have gone through and when you want
to compute the gradient it can't just
back trace it for you and do you know
the backward computation for you so
after so now we're just performing this
dot product within this scope and a
system have record of it so after this
when you want to compute okay what is
the gradient on my left-hand side and
right-hand side tensor you just call
backward on the out so now after this
call the gradient for both left hand
side and right hand side will be in
there dot grad
respectively okay so so with all those
being said let's now take a look at an
example on how do we build a model with
this new interface so let's do it step
by step so first we definitely want to
get our environment ready so we are
importing our MP module and PX module so
this is an extra step that we are doing
because we so historically MX net was
not supporting a lot of the features and
we want to maintain backward
compatibility of for our for the legacy
users so we added this extra call to
switch extent to its numpy compatible
mode and we are so sings we are also
using the auto grab functionality we are
also importing the autocrat and we are
borrowing the theta loaders from Google
interface so we're just importing all
those four things so now we want to
prepare our data loader so we are we're
operating on fashion amidst a data set
which you know it's examples looks like
this it consists of images of size 28 by
28 and they are all pictures of the
fashion goods so we want to classify
them into their corresponding categories
so that is our task so for the data
loader we're just powering the coolest
vision data set and we are you know
designing some pre-processing to it and
then in the end we get to iterators for
the data set for both training and test
data sets so we will be trying to make
this more numpy native more friendly and
so note that we are also leveraging
parallelism here we are specifying the
number of workers which will be the
workers the number of parallel workers
used for the pre-processing of the data
now let's move on to actually build our
model so we've got the data source ready
and the design of the model is actually
really simple for easier understanding
and so the model is designed to be a two
layer multi-layer perceptron with so so
the input size is 784 which is the
result of 28 by 28
so it's 784 pixels and we have a hidden
layer of size 225 256 and we are
categorizing all the inputs into one of
the ten categories so the output number
the number of output is just ten right
and here we're just initializing are we
randomly in initializing other weights
and bias weights and bias for the two
layers and we're collecting them so that
is it's easily managed into a list we
call perhaps for each of them as I've
shown previously we're attaching a
gradient buffer to it because all those
would affect how the output of our model
right so there are all the variables of
the models output so we want to update
them and so we want to hold the gradient
we want to compute and hold the gradient
up there so now let's define our model
so let's take a look at this line first
so we are reshaping the inputs so those
were exercised by 28 by 28 pictures we
want to reshape them into batch size by
784 pixels right and so we so for the
inputs after they are reshaped we dot
product them where's the weight and we
add the bias of the first layer to them
and then we pass the output of this into
the activation function which is a
regularized linear unit so regularize
linear unit is a kind of you know
activation function which is defined as
if you your input is bigger than zeros
and we just returned that
input but if it's less than zero we just
return zero so it's you can see it's
easily implemented with native vampire
but we are also providing you this in
the MPX interface in the MPX namespace
as I just said and so after the
activation function we get the output of
the hidden layer right we referred we
further dot product with the second
layers wait and we add the bias of the
second layer to it right and then now we
reach the output for our model right so
this is just the forward function of the
model we will not be handwriting our
backward function because we are just
gonna use the automatic differentiation
to handle it right so now let's also
define okay how do we measure our how
our model is performing right so we want
to define a last function so now we are
using the softmax cross-entropy loss
function so softmax is a function that
could that will so for any output it
will just compute the probability of
each output so all the output of softmax
were just sum to one for any single
input sample and so for the last we are
computing softmax so which will return
the probability for each of the ten
categories of every single sample from
the data set and we are taking the log
of that probability and we are
multiplying with the value of that label
so if the label is zero then we're just
multiplying with nothing right so if the
label is 1 which means okay
it's that category then we are just
multiplying it with one so we sum all
the loss up then we get a total loss of
dispatch and so this is the loss
function and this is softmax function so
we also have this available under MPX
namespace and now we defined optimizer
which is a stochastic gradient descent
so for
each parameter in it we take its
gradient after it's computed and we
multiply it with the learning rate and
we average it by the size of the badge
and we so here we are also adding a
regularization trick which is a weight
decay to regularize the model to prevent
from overfitting so so after that we
also want to evaluate say because loss
is just a floating number right we also
want to it's not the wreck we also want
to see okay how accurate is our model so
we are also defining those helper
functions to measure the accuracy so
here we have so the input is actually a
batch size by 1/10 right so we are
trying to get okay among which of the
ten values do we have the maximum value
that is we want to use that as our
prediction of the model so we're doing
our max here and we're comparing against
the label the label is just a single
number from 0 to 9 which denotes which
class it is right so if it is the same
then we say we have a correct prediction
all right and for the for evaluating the
total accuracy we want to go through
every every sample in the data set and
then we want to calculate a number of
correct some examples using this
function and we are also summing up the
number of the total number of examples
so dividing those two we get the rate
the the percentage that we are getting
it right so with all those set up now
let's get ready to train our model so we
just train for very short very small
number of epochs and so here we can see
right for each epoch we are going
through the training data set right and
we are doing the forward pass here
wrapped in the record scope
so that the system will handle the
tracing of the operators for us and then
what and since we want to minimize our
loss so we're computing the gradient of
the other parameters with respect to the
with respect to the loss right so now we
call the last backward function so after
this call all the gradient for the
parameters we defined previously will be
ready in their dot grad buffer and then
we can just call updater
the the optimizer to optimize those
parameters toward our ideal result and
so we are so we are also keeping track
of how our model is performing during
the training so we want to compute the
loss we want to compute the accuracy and
so at the end of each epoch that is we
finished one round of training we also
want to validate it on the test data set
to see how it is actually doing in the
wild right so so at the end of each
epoch I'm printing out the epoch ID and
the last accuracy of on post training
training and test data set and here's
the visualization of a sample training
we can see that with just that code our
loss is constantly decreasing and there
is no big gap between the training and
test accuracies which means we are in
pretty good shape for this model you can
actually build more complicated models
too but you know just with the similar
tricks and definitely you you're just
not training a model for fun right so
you want to put it into production so we
are providing an easier pass for you so
other than Python we support seven other
languages which includes Giulia closure
our C++ Perl Java and Scala so any
production system your engineers
welcome we can try to make it work on it
so there are separate tutorials on how
to export your model and deploy it on
different language bindings or yeah so
another thing I want to cover is that we
do have a an ecosystem the first thing
in the ecosystem is that we have
developed a deep learning textbook which
is totally based on this new interface
actually so it comes with code and you
know mathematical formulas and also we
provided discussion forum together with
it
so it's Chinese version has already been
published and it's it was a number one
bestseller on the biggest online
retailer in China so it's also adopted
by more than 25 universities globally as
your textbook or reference book for
their deep learning courses and it's
accessible for free at this link very
short and another part of our ecosystem
that we are providing a lot of
ready-to-use toolkits we have blue on CV
for computer vision features we have an
LP for natural language processing we
also have a clue on TS for time series
modeling and we and a graphic numeral
networks has been hot these days we are
also having a library called eg a
library on craft neural networks so what
do we want to do in the future for this
new package one thing is definitely we
want to extend our coverage to more
functionality features from operator ap
is in official numpy and we also want to
push our performance to the next level
continuously and one way to do it is
that we are integrating with apache TVM
which is a deeply deep learning compiler
for generating tunable computation
kernels on different devices actually
and we also want to enable deployment on
various hardware including the popular
CPU GPU and also ARM based
such as Raspberry Pi
we also via our cooperation with Apache
TV so the slides are over so all the
scripts shown are available at this link
so this link is also available on a on
this talk schedule I'm also gonna show
that show the actual running of some of
the code I just showed to you ok so this
is a part this is the part that we that
is used to show the interoperability
between us and officer not official
numpy package so if you run this we can
see that here the type of so after week
after the creation the type of a is just
our numpy in the array and after calling
the official non-biased function we
still get and mix that numpy on the
array and so yeah this pretty much shows
the interoperability between us and
official umpire so this so we can also
like verify that this result is correct
by maybe we can print out the results
say if we just insert a cell and we
print see and so if we want to do this
an official numpy we have a way to cast
our nd arrays to official numpy on the
arrays which is as numpy function call
so if we run this you can see the
results are pretty much just the same
right
which verifies the correctness of the
computation so here is an example of the
auto grad functionality so here when we
are attaching the gradient we allocate a
new buffer to it so like if we we can
try to print our print one of them out
and we can see the result of it after
the backward Kong so after attaching the
back good the gradient the buffer
contains all zeros so it's like and
written right so after the backward call
it's filled with the gradient with
respective of out with respective to
left hand side so you don't have to
actually implement the backward function
at all
so here here's the model training
example that I just showed so we're
importing without a problem and we are
preparing the data loader
and we are did you know initializing the
parameters here and we're defining the
model computation here which is exactly
the same code which is also available in
the github repo so this is the last part
all right we're we're calculating the
cross entropy of the softmax output and
we this is the optimizer and this is the
definition for the accuracy metrics and
here is the actual training loop so
let's run it to see if it works so we
can see after epoch zero our accuracy is
about 68% and then the loss is
decreasing
both accuracies are kind of in a trend
to go up so we are
just happens on CPU if you put it on GPU
it could be even faster but since this
is a really small net newer network then
we just don't even need a GPU so after
tiny pokes of training we can see we are
reaching a training accuracy of about 85
percent and has accuracy of 82%
so now let's maybe take a look at how
this is doing on actual data set so
let's visualize the predictions so the
label above is is it's the ground choose
which is a t-shirt and now we're
predicting it as a t-shirt so we're good
and you know so for all the other
pictures the one above is the tranches
and the one below is the it's our models
prediction so we can see we're doing
pretty good on four of those for this we
were kind of tricked all right and did I
always say this one really looks like a
shirt right yeah so that's pretty much
it and any questions um I'm just curious
if you could go over like some of the
main highlights of how MX net is better
than tensor flow or pi torch or like
other common deep learning tools and
then my other question is if like the
original numpy updates and stuff are you
inheriting from that or like how does
that get pulled into your code so to
answer your first question I think
firstly we we definitely actually grew
support for distributed training that's
why my point and also as I said we have
a quite smooth deployment pass we also
as I just mentioned we have cooperation
with Apache TVM on also deploying your
model to your edge devices if you have
any and on the other hand about the
updates on the numpy side we are we have
a team with more than ten people
dedicated to keep keep this package
going keeping it updated with the latest
numpy so right now we are matching the
behavior of 1.17 so if 1.18 comes out we
also identify the gaps and
keep working on it okay thanks for you
passion and feel free to reach out to me
on github if you have any questions
regarding this package